desperate to leave the russian
occupation they cycled and walked for
hours under cover of darkness
are you going to kill me says this woman
suspicious as the ukrainian police
register new arrivals
this was their fourth attempt to flee
the gerson region where life had become
unbearable says vladimir
putin
the air is different here he says
to stay there was more dangerous we
decided to take the risk
there were attempts for humanitarian
corridors and people went to the meeting
point with white flags
but the soldiers dispersed us and said
if you want a corridor then go to crimea
that's when people started finding other
ways to reach the ukrainian side what's
the level of supernatural
where bikes wheelchairs prams and even
wheelbarrows are held people used
whatever they had she says
so the russians about three kilometers
away from here those coming out of the
themson region have to cross the lines
alone in this no man's land between the
two armies and hope not to get caught in
the crossfire
it's a treacherous passage but it's the
only escape route
thank you guys we're waiting for you he
says
the army is holding his defensive
position but ukraine claims the russians
are preparing for a major push here
and there is fear that the soldiers
could be outgunned
while most of the western weapons head
to the dumbass region in the east of the
country
[Music]
we need heavy weapons artillery javelins
drones because they have a lot of
weapons the russians don't care about
saving their soldiers lives and they
advance like works
hundreds of them lie in the fields
nobody collects the bodies but they have
a lot of weapons
the villages along the contact line come
under shelling the rumble of artillery
sounds at regular intervals
but it's the fear of an imminent
annexation just like what happened in
crimea and in donbass eight years ago
that are pushing people to cross front
lines on their own
al jazeera in southern ukraine